you told me about the guns of August by
Barbara tuckman it's a it's a book on
World War I and I went down a whole
Rabbit Hole there is like an incredible
historian but anyway the there's a bunch
of stuff you learn from that but one of
the things you told me is it influenced
your general approach to diplomacy of
just picking up the phone and giving it
a try so as opposed to planning and uh
strategizing just pick up the phone
yeah so so this was a book I read uh way
before the notion of serving in
government uh was ever even on my mind
or or reality and I remember thinking
about it reading it and thinking how
World War I started where you had um you
know somebody was assassinated and then
you had all these different alliances
that were created and then in order to
accomplish objectives it triggered all
of these um people getting in bed with
everyone else because of documents that
were created without the intent of going
to a massive war and I think in the
course of World War I it was one of the
greatest uh atrocities that we've seen
as Humanity we've had 16 million people
killed in that war and I as I was
reading the book I remember thinking to
myself even though you know things are
set in a certain way go sit with
somebody go talk to them and say this
doesn't make sense this is wrong how do
we create a better pathway and as a
civilian all my life you know I would
read the newspapers I would I would I
would you know observe how different
leaders would act but when we have the
opportunity to serve in government and
have uh the position you realize you're
not a civilian you don't have the luxury
of sitting back and letting the world
happen the way it's happening you have
agency and you have uh the potential to
influence the outcome of things and one
thing I've seen is you know most
political prognosticators are wrong
anyone who tells you what's going to
happen really has no clue and it's not
because they're bad or they're not
intelligent it's because nobody knows
and at the end of the day the outcomes
in the world are usually driven by the
decisions of of humans and if you're
able to come together form relationships
listen to each other uh you can do that
and one of the great examples uh that I
speak about in the book is with North
Korea whereas if you remember in
2017 it was very intense when President
Obama was leaving office he told
president Trump that the single biggest
fear that he had and this is a time when
the world was a mess you had uh the
Middle East was on fire Isis was
ping journalists and killing Christians
they to califate the size of Ohio Libya
was destabilized Yemen was destabilized
Syria was in a civil war where 500,000
people were killed Iran was on a Glide
path to a nuclear weapon yet the single
biggest fear he had was North Korea then
it got compounded by the fact that we
get into office and president Trump
brings his generals around and he's you
know learning how to interact with all
the generals and says okay what are my
options and they said calm down we've
been using all of our ammunition in the
Middle East we don't have enough
ammunition to go to war over there and
he says let's not let's not let that be
due public let's try to restock and come
up with a plan yeah and at the time
there was a lot of banter back and forth
and uh you know I was able to I got a
call from a friend who was a an old
business contact who actually had done
business in North Korea and he said you
know I'd love to find a way to solve
this and I was getting calls from
friends at the time saying I'm trying to
go to Hawaii for a vacation should I not
be going is it not safe I mean we forget
forget the psychology of how intense
that was at the time and then through
that interaction he caught some of his
contacts in North Korea and then we were
able with the CIA to open up a back
channel that ultimately led to the the
deescalation the meeting between Trump
and Kim Jung good which led to a
deescalation so that was really the
mindset which was whenever there's a
problem just pick up the phone and try
and I think president Trump had a very
similar approach which was let's let's
give it a shot and he wasn't afraid to
go after the hard ones too and I'll say
one final thing on this which is that in
politics the incentive structure is just
much different than in the real world
right in the sense that you have a hard
problem then if you try to solve a hard
problem the likelihood of failure is
great whereas in the business world if
you're going after a hard problem we
celebrate those people right we we we
want our entrepreneurs and our great
people to go after solving the big hard
problems but in politics if you try to
take on a hard problem you have a high
likelihood of failure you'll get a lot
of criticism uh on your pathway to
trying to accomplish that if you fail
and then if you fail it has a higher
probability of leading to you losing
your opportunity to serve and so it's
just one of these things where people
want to play it safe which is not the
notion that that that really was taken
during the time that President Trump was
in office do you think it has to be that
way I think I think there's something in
in the human Spirit like in the public
that desires politicians to take big
take on the big bold problems right like
why why is it the politicians need to be
so afraid of failure I don't think it
has to be that way and that's I think
one of the great lessons from the time
of the the Trump Administration he
brought a lot of people from the
business world into government uh the
business people have a much different
mindset than government people and there
was a lot of resistance and I think part
of why there was so much resistance was
because you know I think about it my
personal sense was that if I was
successful with no traditional
qualifications to do diplomacy it meant
that all the people with traditional
qualifications and diplomacy didn't
necessarily need those qualifications in
order to be successful and that same
that same sentiment manifested itself in
many areas in government and and I think
that in the business world it's it's
outcome oriented it's results oriented
and you know what we would see in in New
York is there they would stab you in the
eye and DC they would stab you in the
back and it just became a whole
Dynamic of of of how you work through
these different areas so the answer is
it doesn't have to be that way you just
need the right courageous leader and
that's why I'm so optimistic about what
the future of America and the world
could be if you have the right people in
power who are willing to take on the
right challenges and do it in the right
way so if we just lingered on the North
Korea and the deescalation and the
meeting what's the
trajectory from this could be the most
catastrophic thing that destroys the
world
to you find back channels you start
talking and start arranging the meeting
like is there some insights you can give
to how difficult that is to do in that
in in the North Korea case which seems
like to be one of the more closed off
parts of the world and in the other
cases that you worked on yeah it's it's
always very challenging and especially
when you're going against the grain of
what's established right we did
something different to think that an old
business contact that I had could then
do it I mean that's the type of thing
that you know if the Press knew what we
were doing they would have you know
derided it and criticized it in Every
Which Way but that was one of the
benefits of operating very much below
the radar is that we were able to try
all these different things and not all
of them worked but some of them did and
you know but that is what's amazing
about the world right this could be the
biggest story on the front page of every
paper and they're inciting fear and
everyone and it's not illegitimate fear
I mean there were missile test uh you
know over over Japan I mean you had a
lot of uh very CH big challenges with
that file and then all of a sudden we
make contact we go through negotiations
to set a meeting there's a meeting
between President Trump and Kim Jung gun
and then all of a sudden there's there's
a framework um to try and move things
forward um and again I think that
there's a lot of possibility there for
what could happen if it's worked in the
right way I just want to know like how
you word that first email or text
message like what emojis to use like the
hugging Emoji I it's just personally
I've gotten to know a lot of powerful
and uh rich people and just it's funny
that they're all human just like you're
saying and like a lot of the drama a lot
of the problems can be resolved with
just like a little camaraderie a little
kindness a little like just actually
just reaching out we're all human beings
and and people want to be successful and
people want to be good and and you're
right too there's there's way more
emojis involved in diplomacy than I ever
would have expected but and every leader
I'm sure has their favorite emoji this
is also I learned about people they use
like they there's the everybody has
their go-to Emoji like you go to the
heart very quickly Emoji there's some
people who go the hugging whatever that
where you're like do the hugging thing
anyway uh this conversation quickly
turned to the
ridiculous